Hello and welcome to Kryptosi Vest 2.
This is a, I guess, state of the project
video. We're going to release these
videos along every step
of the way until Cryptosy Vest is
complete. This is the second
episode. For the first episode, I guess
you can go into description below. I'll
put the first episode there, but.
A quick recap, Kryptosi Vest is
you can almost ignore this
website we've got over this side
here. You can always ignore it because
it's a quick thing I had made-up
by AI. So the
the final landing page will not look like
this. Just using this as a placeholder
for now. So the website
we've bought the domain will be
cryptosyvest dot tech.
Cryptosyst is a tool to
shield you against rug pools. And
it is completely decentralisable. It will
be completely decentralised when it's
complete. Currently we are in the
development stage. We are just in the
second stage of development out of the
9 or 10 stages that I like to, I
like to put and in this short video,
what we're going to do is go through the
stages of development that there will be
in the future, as well as
rounding up what's going to happen in
this particular station at this
particular stage is the. Picking
of the team who from the cryptosy
team will be the people
to create and bring this
cryptosyvest project to life.
So in this.
First thing we'll do is go through the
steps, then we'll cover the team. So the
steps are as follows. We developed
the logo and the brand.
No need to do a video for that really.
The the logo is a Logan a brand is the
brand. I will show you the logo very
quickly though this will be the logo
moving forward. And obviously the
brand will be based around this
particular symbol will be the logo
and this font
anti rug platform is the the line.
So we know what it is we're doing
so. Let's go
to Yeah. So after
that we will make a video about.
Or hold on, maybe we've got we'll make a
video about the team, which is really
what we're making now. Then we're going
to show you the logic document. Logic
document is actually currently finished,
but we won't show you that in this video.
I'll make another video about that at a
later date. There might be some
changes needed to the logic document,
maybe a few little tweaks here and there.
We'll then create wireframes. Of course,
the logic document will show. How a
person will navigate through the
application?The wire frames then brings
that to life. So the wire frames are also
completed. We're currently working on the
front end Figma, which will be the
designs, exactly how the app will
look. We will create the smart contracts.
That's going to be done by our developer.
We will reveal who the developer will be
very soon, integrate the
two together. So front end and
the smart contracts get integrated
together. There will be a back end,
but it will be a system so that.
It's fully decentralised. Anybody can
spin up their own back end. Anybody can
have their own database and run their own
version of Cryptosyst.
We'll then go through testing. Testing
will be done mostly by myself. I'll see
if I can get some help and usability from
the lights of Chocker Block, people like
that. And then we launch.
Then we start to consider future
features. So who will
be the developer
for this particular project?
And the developer will be
this man. His name is
Snowman, also known as Bino.
He has done quite a lot of work for us in
the past prior to going
AWOL and then coming back.
We can see his befores and his after.
He's not actually on the team
page at the moment, but we will put
him on there prior to
obviously paying him.
He'll take one of these two placeholder
spaces here, so he'll take over Jane
Smith or Tom Black because those people
don't actually exist. A
little spoiler there with Amidas. So
this will be our developer if we go and
have a brief look, we can see in our
GitHub for Bitify. He
was Snowman 108.  Heis now buying no
snow. He has added
by it now. He's done quite a lot of work
on bit of Fire actually, and he also done
quite a lot of work on Ruby swap so.
Decent developer I would say. Possibly
not our best but.
Definitely more than capable of
handling this project
that we are currently building. Of course
everything that he builds will be open
source and everything that he builds will
be audited. And realistically
the whole point in decentralised open
sourcesoftware is
that we're not trusting the person who
developed it. That's the reason why we
have verified contracts and that's the
reason why we have. Code audits.
So we will be going through all of those
things. Before the platform
is launched. So Bino
will be albino will be
the developer behind it here he is here
we there is already a
YouTube video with Bino
where you get to CNB interviewed by
myself. That is me that gorgeous man
there on the left hand side rocking my
signature higher on base
cap and.
Yeah, so. If you want
to know more about the developer, just go
and check him out videos there
on our YouTube. It's under the Crypto C
team. Bunch of videos
so that shouldn't shouldn't be too hard
to find. We
also need a person who will be
in charge of doing the design,
and that person is drum
roll, Please Amide. There's Timothy,
known in our discord as Figo
Lord. He's done quite a lot of design
work for us before. He's a Nigerian man,
very, very talented designer,
hard working and
definitely somebody who we can rely
on to bring. A nice
vibrant. Wireframe to
life. So we are
delighted to have him available for
this project. I really think that gives
us a good chance to have a very, very
nice front end for our
first. Minimum viable
product. So very, very happy to have
Amidas on board or Figo Lord on
board. He has worked with us before
on Sunak means.
I think that's the only roject he's
worked with us on O This will be his
second time but we were hay with what we
got for cine memes so hopefully he can
deliver the same standard of work and we
can have a beautiful front end.
Asides from that, I think
that pretty much is it as far as
testing is concerned. Like I said, it
will more than likely be me doing the
testing. If you are interested in
testing, obviously you could join our
discord as well as if you are
interested in joining the team or being a
part of this project, please join our
discord. Everything we do always build in
the open so anybody who wants to
chip in can chip in. Being paid,
obviously, is a different beast
altogether. We are trying
to eliminate
fraudulent efforts to be
paid by people who are not actually
developers, which is the reason why the
whole Cryptosy team came about, so that
only the verified people can get paid.
And we verify them obviously by having a
video with them. And I'm never paying the
same address. So that's the team that's
going to be the team behind.
Crypto C vest hopefully we should
continue to.
Build at this rapid pace, we're
aiming for AQ1 launch.
It's looking dicey at the moment,
probably be Q2 at this point
realistically, but the smart contract
development is underway, the wireframes
are complete and the design is now being
created so.
With any luck, we should be able to
release in Q1 or maybe Q2,
robably Q2. Anyway, thanks for watching.
If you are interested in this project at
all, make sure you follow me on Twitter.
Alternatively, you can join our Discord.
I will put the link in the description
below and away from that. Thanks
for watching and I look forward to seeing
you using the Crypto C
REST platform. Peace.